[Musique]
Darat bonjour bonjour Patrice alors je
voulais vous je voulais parler avec vous
parce que vous êtes un un jeune élu vous
êtes élu à la verrière vous êtes adjoint
au maire de la verrière du développement
économique du commerce mais aussi de de
la jeunesse et je voudrais qu'on qu'on
évoque avec vous la verrière qui était
gravement touché par par les émeutes à
la fin du mois de juin au mois de
juillet et je voudrais qu'on regarde
cette ville qu'est-ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui quelques mois après ces
émeutes vous êtes aussi un un un
militant LR hein fa parti des jeunesses
LR c'est ça oui toujours hein et puis
donc il y a eu un il y a un un
changement dans ce département avec
l'élection à la présid présidence de la
fédération l de Hotman
nasrou qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça
change pour vous comm en tant que
militant en tant que militant pas
grandchose si je peux dire puisque nous
que ça soit d'ailleurs je tiens à
féliciter otman Nasr pour la campagne
qu'il a fait il a gagné vraiment
largement gagé mais Philippe benassa n'a
pas non plus démérité moi je pense que
cette élection qui est interne au partis
va pas changer peut-être la face du
monde on est bien d'accord hein bon mais
en ça revanche je pense que c'est ce
sont des élections très importantes pour
mobiliser encore plus de militants
incarner peut-être un nouveau souffleou
et surtout de se réunir autour des
valeurs qui nous sont propres nous la
droite moi je suis un fervant militant
vous le savez des républicains je suis
de droite je suis très bien d'être de
droite par pourquoi vous êtes de droite
d'ailleurs parce que pour moi être de
droite vous savez c'est déjà la
transmission des valeurs des valeurs
fortes qui sont le mérite le travail
l'amour de la patrie et aujourd'hui je
me reconnais pas dans d'autres parties
c'est pour ça depuis toujours je suis de
droite il y a une phrase de Romain gar
que moi j'aime beaucoup je n'ai pas une
seule goutte de sonang français mais la
France coule dans mes veines et pour moi
oui vous êtes vous êtes de quelle
origine cambodienne d'accord donc vous
voyez je me retrouve pas dans les autres
parties c'est c'est c'est vos parents
qui qui ont qui sonts ont quitté le
régime communiste descmer rouge Paul po
de Paul pote vous le
savez et et voilà moi je pense que être
un Français assimilé h sans Rener mes
origines pour autant et la droite pour
moi est un est un courant politique qui
euh permet cette assimilation là qui
permet de mettre si je peux dire les les
l'histoire de France un idéal français h
au-dessus des je dirais des des
appartenances des origines exactement ou
des origines ou des origines mais est-ce
que pardon he mais le le le drame en
effet qui a été le
la toute l'histoire des mer rouges avec
avec des des milliers de morts enfin et
et et l'idée de changer l'homme aussi
hein cétait il y avait cette idée là che
chez Paul pot est-ce que ça joue aussi
dans votre engagement peut-être sans
doute sans doute hein sans doute parce
que je vais vous dire aujourd'hui quand
je vois ce qui s'est passé aux émeutes
de la verrière on voit bien qu'il y a
une fracture dans le pays il y a une
fracture dans le pays parce que les
jeunes il s reconnaissent plus dans
l'identité française si je peux dire
dans son histoire dans peut-être ces
valeurs qu'elle transmet pour moi la
politique normalement c'est rendre
possible ce qui est nécessaire et
aujourd'hui on voit bien que l'État est
en faillite en faillite au niveau social
au niveau économique et au niveau
politique l'incarnation finalement et je
pense on a l'impression que l'État a de
moins en moins de pouvoir et de moyens
et moins de moyens et pourtant depuis
2010 l'état injecte plus de 110
milliards d'euros dans la politique de
la ville je n'ai jamais vu le pays aussi
fracturé quand on voit les deux écoles
sur trois incendie à La Verrière c'est
quand même à se poser des questions
j'ajoute que au niveau des de l'élection
des républicains moi je suis très
content Cotman soit aujourd'hui
président de notre fédération j'espère
qu'il mobilisera encore plus de
militants et qu'il puisse transmettre
nos valeurs qui nous sont chers mais
aujourd'hui il faut travailler dans le
fond il faut travailler sur l'autorité
la responsabilité sur
l'éducation sur la parentalité tant de
sujets qui aujourd'hui sont majeurs
parce que on voit bien s'il y a eu ces
ces émeutes là ça vient pas de il y a 5
ans ou ou de la cause du président de la
République Macron hein ça vient de
beaucoup plus il y a un vieux vieux
contentieux conteneux il monte il monte
alors on on va parler dans une dans un
instant un mot encore sur la sur la la
politique la politique politicienne on
pourrait dire mais euh vous êtes vous
êtes jeune je le disais j'en ai lu
euh un un parti politique c'est pas
quand même un vieux machin ah ça c'est
une ét bon
alors je vous répond franchement c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué il y a
d'autres moyens il y a les réseaux
sociaux il y a les internets c'est
compliqué je l'accorde non c'est
compliqué je l'accorde d'ailleurs
maintenant on voit bien qu'à travers les
réseaux sociaux chacun essaie de donner
de son opinion et cetera sauf qu'un
parti c'est d'être plus fort ensemble
d'accord l'idée d'un parti c'est cela à
la base et comme je l'ai dit à la base
la racine de la politique c'est rendre
possible ce qui est nécessaire et
aujourd'hui euh les partis se délitent
on voit bien la nuupè est totalement
maintenant alors il y a des nouveaux
partis qui n'arrivent
pas à voir à se faire entendre sur le
plan sur le plan local notamment en
parti c'est important on le voit bien
regardez moi je suis euh de droite le
département est de droite la région est
de droite et regardez ce qui s'est passé
et les mairies sont de droite surtout
dans les évelines député ah ça c'est
c'est autre chose VO on va parler en
tout cas ce qu'on peut observer c'est
que lorsque on est dans un parti
politique on le voit très bien même au
niveau local ça va beaucoup plus vite et
je pourrais peut-être y revenir au
niveau de la verrière mais quand on a a
des partenaires qui sont si je peux dire
du même parti qui ont la même vision h
de la vie politique c'est beaucoup plus
simple je dirais de de mener des projets
d'accord donc donc donc pensez pensez
que que les partis politiques ont encore
un intérêt j'ai j'ai parler avec Otman
nasrou qui qui est venu ici quand il
faisait ça B pour pour annoncer sa
candidature et on parler justement de la
situation d'olr qui vous le disiez elle
est forte dans ce département dans les
villes euh
et et elle est faible sur le plan
national et lui dit reconnaî si on
narrive pas à reconquérir sur le plan
national bah ce qui se passe sur le plan
national se passera au niveau du
département et au niveau local vous êtes
d'accord avec ça totalement aligné
totalementman apporté une une très belle
vision là-dessus nous ce qu'on cherche
en tout cas chez les LR c'est de
rassembler la jeunesse comme nos SCOR
mais surtout de reconnecter les Français
à des valeurs qui sont très simples le
mérite le droit la réussite la
responsabilité et le respect de
l'autorité c'est les valeurs pour moi de
la droite voilà aujourd'hui on voit bien
que la droite est aussi divisée on a vu
avec l'apparition vous savez de
génération Z avec Eric Zemour Marine Le
Pen gagne du terrain les sont divisés
entre le centre gauche avec Macron et en
même temps on voit bien que la main
tendue vers l'extrême droite donc la
question vrai problème aujourd'hui où
ils son c'est retrouver notre boussole
et je pense queman a compris qu'il
fallait avoir des valeurs solides fortes
ancrées pour mobiliser d'accord on verra
donc on verra moi je Souha bonne chance
en tout cas moi on est dans un esprit de
rassembllement pour les
européennes vous vous avez un candidat
de présélection oui François Xav Bel Ami
ouis j'apprécie énormément c'est un ami
je trouve que c'est quelqu'un qui
connaît ses sujets c'est le premier par
exemple je vous donne là un exemple mais
c'était le premier à être monté au
créneau par rapport vous savez à la
guerre qui se passe en Arménie
avecazerbajan sur le haut carabach
c'était le premier à avoir porté ce
sujet là à la Commission européenne et
donc je pense que François Xav benami
est l'un des acteur je dirais nouveau
qui va permettre de donner un nouveau
souffle à la droite c'est un philosophe
il est
versaillais il était il était tête de
liste aux dernières élections
européennes voilà peut-être qu'il le
sera aussi en en 2024 alors parlons de
la
verrière ça a été une des cités des des
villes les plus touchées oui par les
émeutes avec notamment des écoles qui
ont été détruites vous vous disiez
d'ailleurs il y a C symbole on a parlé
beaucoup de de symbole de la République
qui avait été détruit est-ce qu'on a pas
été un peu un peu vite et un peu loin en
disant ça est-ce que est-ce que les les
jeunes qui sont attaqués en effet aux
écoles aux
mairies ils sont pas simplement attaqués
à ce qui était autour d'eux avant de
avant de dire c'est des symboles je ve
vous dire déjà c'est personnes là qui
ont incendié l'école de leurs petits
frèrees petites sœur je pense qu'il y a
un gros problème tout d'abord sur
l'éducation oui première chose deux sur
l'autorité parce qu'ils se sont dit si
on va jamais se faire rattraper mais il
faut revenir sur le contexte la crise
les émeutes qui se sont passé cet été
elles sont d sous cette affaire vous
savez naë absolument ça suit voilà ce
n'était qu'un prétexte nous sommes bien
d'accord ils ont barricadé les rues
unendie deux écoles une école maternelle
et l'école élémentaire du des l'école
des Noé qui est l'école maternelle et
l'école du boî dest le groupe scolaire
ils ont privé de 200 enfants de leur
école de l'école absolument qui comme je
le rappelle c'est l'école de leurs petit
frères et petites sœurs ce sont des
criminels le deuxème point nous il
fallait réagir d'urgence il fallait tout
de suite relocaliser nos enfants dans
les les écoles qui nous restent par
chance il nous en restait qu'une c'est
le RPD l'école régionale de premier
degré qui situe à 20 minutes du
quartier par chance c'est que la
capacité d'accueil de l' RP é était
suffisant tout à fait très grande c'est
400 enfants
possibles il y avait pas 400 doncaris
h classes ont été ouvertes immédiatement
on a pu tout de suite relocaliser nos
enfants deuxème point il fallait le
moins possible impacter la scolarité de
nos enfants donc mettre en place des
navettes comme je l'ai dit c'est à 20
minutes quand même du quartier et grâce
à l'impulsion du maire Nicolas d'ville
et notre adjointe ad Lopez on a pu
mettre en place ces navettes là
évidemment je remercie la région j'en
profite pour remercier la région
d'île-defance Valérie pcres qui s'est
mobilisé
et la communauté d'agglomération de 50
en Iline et Jean-Michel Fourgous qui
était vraiment là au tout début pour
justement mettre en place ses navettes
c'est quand même un budget de 300000 €
hein que Patrice pour on vous aperçoit à
côté de Gabriel Atal qui est qui est qui
est venu ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui qui c'éta sa prière visite
en fait voilà première visite a été pour
la verrière et pour ses écoles détruite
c'est vrai que alors il y a il y a il y
a ce drame un peu incompréhensible de de
jeunes qui détruisent les écoles
c'est-à-dire le moyen par lesquels euh
peut-être ils pourraient réussir leur
vie donc on se dit c'est complètement
euh contradictoire et puis il y a cette
solidarité de l'État euh de la Région du
Département et et même de et de sa tout
fait et c'est et c'est c'est ça qui est
qui a été dans notre malheur on a eu de
la chance et qu'il y a eu un élant de
solidarité tant par la Région le
Département en premier lieu euh la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 ans
d'inglin euh aujourd'hui on a eu même
une cagnotte que vous savez des nous
avons reçu des tonnes de fournitures
scolaires des dons plus de 2500 € ont
été récoltés pour justement donner un
peu plus de moyens à nos enfants pour
préparer la rentrée en temps et en heure
et dans de bonnes conditions aujourd'hui
maintenant on pense à la reconstruction
nous euh avec le département des
ivelines et la municipalité ce qu'on
veut c'est que d'ici 3 ans l'école soit
réouverte qu'un nouveau groupe scolaire
euh arrive d'c 2026 c'est à peu près
c'est ça ça on va tout faire pour que ça
soit ça le plus vite possible puis qu'on
est d'accord que c'est pas tenable
d'envoyer les enfants un quartier dans
un autre quartier c'est pas tenable il
faut que ça soit mais c'était la
solution parce que il y Ava presque 200
élèves qui se retrouv sans école il faut
le savoir on a veillé que 2 mois pour
préparer la rée de nos enfants et c'est
quand même 200 enfants concernés donc
les navettes c'est bien beau mais là
faut penser à l'avenir donc le groupe
scolaire il faut savoir que sur le
budget euh la ver a très peu de budget
pour faire ça on a que 12 millions
d'euros de budget annuel h vous savez
combien coûte école on estime à peu près
à 27 million d'euros le nouveau la
nouvelle école c'est 1 million d'euros
par classe ouais vous écoutez bien on n
pas les moyens le département et je
remercie Pierre Bédier justement d'avoir
donné son appui là-dessus pour qu'on
puisse reconstruire dans les plus brefs
délais cette nouvelle école du mois
d'éts aussi il faut péréniser nos
efforts au niveau de la commune sur la
parentalité j'en ai parlé l'éducation
euh aujourd'hui nous par exemple nous
avons signé vous savez on a pérénisé un
partenariat avec avec le Conservatoire
musique baroque de Versailles pour
mettre en avant la richesse patrimoniale
de notre pays on a mis en place le coup
de course pour un emploi pour justement
donner l'accès à l'emploi plus
facilement à nos habitants le troisième
point nous avons mis en place aussi la
soirée des réussites pour mettre en
avant les talents de la verrière puisque
aujourd'hui on récompense pas assez
l'ffort vous voyez bien pourquoi je suis
de
droite mais oui BF après oui c'est soir
de mérite c'est les gens les jeunes qui
ont le bac not on le B ont le licence
dire voilà que tout effort sera
récompensé si vous travaillez c'est ça
l'idée c'est on peut réussir évidemment
dans le sport dans la musique ce que
vous voulez mais il y a pas que ça comme
voie de réussite on a besoin de juriste
on a des talents au boî des temps pas
qu' au boî des temps har Park et dans le
quartier du village et c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'on c'est ce qu'on veut en tout
cas avec la municipalité qu'on mette en
avant ces talent là qui travaill qui qui
se disent qu'il peuvent réussir en en
faisant des études je dis pas que les
études c'est la voix royale et c'est la
voix oui enfin quand même si on regarde
les gens qui font des études on est
d'accord moins de risque
deage bon voilà on sait on sait quand
même qu' qu'il y a des a des avantages à
ça justement vous dites on a beaucoup de
talents au bois de l'ét temp beaucoup de
jeunes voilà qui qui sortent au fond de
de qui s'arrachent de de milieu grâce
grâce aux études grâce au travail grâce
à et qui leur permet de de de d'accéder
au voies de la réussite mais est-ce que
ce sont les mêmes qui ont été détruire
justement les écoles dans les émeutes
évidemment que non on sait bien que
c'est une minorité c'est 1 % vous les
connaissez bah
non non non je je ne les connais pas
ceux qui ont fait ça vous savez je tra
pas très grand la verrière Mo pas avec
des criminelsat attention non je
plaisente mais bon blague à part ce que
je veux dire c'est que oui c'est on est
bien d'accord c'est qu'une minorité qui
pourrit la vie des habitants hein les
habitants du bois des temps on les
connaît eu ce qu'ils veulent c'est de la
fermeté ils veulent que justement que
lorsqu'il y a une sanction encouru que
la sçon soit véritablement appliquée euh
j'ai je sais aujourd'hui que deux
personnes ont été arrêtées donc là il y
a le secret de l'enquête moi si je vois
et avec toute l'équipe municipale ce
qu'on souhaite c'est que les sanctions
soient véritablement appliqué et soient
ferme ferme puisque ce n'est pas
possible d'être dans les laisser faire
et d'être dans la naïveté et vous savez
hein dans le le Pass droit ouais vous
disiez tout à l'heure au fond ces
émeutes elles viennent de loin oui euh
elles viennent de quoi
parce que c'est c'est compliqué à
expliquer comment comment ça ça surgit
de manière voilà presque inattendue et
comment ça s'est arrêté presque aussi
vite que ça avait commencé ah mais c'est
très simple aujourd'hui on est bien
d'accord que les émeutes de C été c'est
une fracture au niveau de la
transmission la transmission du savoir
des valeurs il y a aussi un problème
d'éducation quand je parle d'éducation
je parle pas de l'éducation nationale
hein non non
d'éducation voilà h des parents il y a
un problème là-dessus l'État peut pas
être comptable de tout on est bien
d'accord qu'il y a un problème
effectivement il on voit la baisse des
niveaux scolair dans nos établissements
on voit bien évidemment qu'il y a un
problème dans la transmission de nos
valeurs que ça soit sur ne serait-ce que
nos valeurs de de vous savez de
républicaine liberté égalité
fraternité vous savez il y a quelque
chose qui m'a marqué il y a un an
j'avais fait la visite de l'Assemblée
nationale avec des des enfants d'accord
personne n'était capable de me dire
moyen âge moyen ils étaient incapabl de
me dire à quoi servait un député oui
voyez ça c'est un vrai problème mais
c'est pourquoi je dis qu'il y a un
problème dans la transmission des
valeurs et aujourd'hui je pense pour
être très honnête aussi pour être très
honnête je pense aussi qu'il y a une
forme de culpabilisation de l'histoire
de France quand on voit ces phénomènes
W c'est c'est une hérésie c'est une
hérésie mais pourquoi on cherche à
est-ce qu'on déconstruireonexagère pas
quand même moi un peu je non Mo
j'exagère pas moi quand je vois ça
çausque on cherche à déboulonner des
statutes du général de
Gaulle de lire l'histoire avec les yeux
d'aujourd'hui
mais Colbert non mais on peut on peut on
peut
aussi comprendre que on veille tout
savoir d'un personnage historique sans
forcément débouonner les statuts c'est
pas ce que je dire mais Colbert c'est à
la fois la naissance de l'État mais
c'est aussi le Code Noir donc voilà
c'est bien de tout dire aussi non c'est
bien mais c'est mais faut pas
culpabiliser non plus h fr la France on
est d'accord elle date pas de 70 ans là
ouais elle a plus de 1500 ans d'
absolument oui non tout ça vient de loin
tout ça vient de très loin et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on on soit
fier d'être français qu'on puisse
transmettre cette fierté là à nos
enfants qu'on puisse leur dire que quand
il y a des règles il faut les respecter
il faut pas sans cesse les contester
quand je vois des députés de gauche qui
cherche à si je peux dire à légitimer
des des des manifestations interdites
par la Préfecture de Police je me dis où
est est où est le respect du droit mais
et à partir du moment on donne pas
l'exemple faut pas s'étonner que les
Françaises et les Français ne cherchent
pas à respecter non plus la loi est-ce
que le fait que je reviens à vous ça
soit quelqu'un qui est
d'origine cambodgienne justement qui
nous disent voilà bah voilà ce que c'est
les valeurs de la République voilà ce
que c'est les valeurs de la France et
j'y crois euh est-ce que vous y croyez
pas plus que au fond les les les les
gens qui sont d'origine française ou
vous savez moi je suis français et peu
importe les origines encore impor les
origines je vais vous dire moi je
suis qu'on renvoie les gens à leurs
origines mais mais je v vous dire il y a
une phrase de Marc block que j'aime
beaucoup Marc block oui c'est grand
historien historien résistant qui disait
je revendique mes origines que dans un
seul cas en face d'un antisémite la
France j'y suis né j'ai bu aux sources
de sa culture j'ai fait M son son
histoire je ne peux respirer bien que
sous son ciel et je m'efforce
aujourd'hui de la défendre de mon mieux
je vous pose une questionce est-ce que
vous pensez que des personnes comme moi
aujourd'hui il y en a beaucoup bah
j'espère un peu j'en doute c'est pour ça
que je me VO mais je suis pas très sûr
oui je suis pas très sûr donc il a un
problème de transmission de valeur avant
toute chose tant au niveau de l'État que
des parents ouais est-ce que justement
vous parliez de de Marc bloc et de
l'antisémitisme on on voit un reg regard
de l'antisémitisme de depuis quelques
depuis enfin euh depuis le le le 7
octobre et depuis l'attaque du du du
Hamas euh est-ce que l'exportation euh
du conflit
israëlopalestinien vous la sentez dans
des dans des villes comme les vôtres
alors nous en tout cas on essaye et
Nicolas d'Inville le maire de La
Verrière eu qui est un élu à mon sens
formidable il tente par tous les moyens
d'éviter justement cet import et comment
on peut l'éviter voilà c'est ça comment
on peut l'éviter tout d'abord en étant
non pas forcément dans la neutralité il
faut condamner les violences de toutes
parts oui mais il faut pas non plus
prendre parti aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'il y a un un état qui cherche à se
défendre h on peut le décrier les
bombardement et de l'autre côté on a un
groupe muscul terroriste qui est le
Hamas qui prend en otage une population
palestinienne h entre autres et qui
prend en otage cette population qui on
le sait tous cache des armes dans des
des établissements publics comme les
hôpitaux des écoles honnêtement quand on
voit des bombardements qui visent les
Palestiniens en tout cas le Hamas on
voit bien les dommages que la TER que ça
fait comment on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas être insensible possible et de
l'autre côté quand on voit l'attaque du
7 octobre l'attaque terroriste du 7 Oob
dans le
kibout pas non plus honnêtement j'ai
l'impression que dans ce conflit vous
savez quoi peu importe ce qu'on dit soit
on risque de se faire insulter so on
risque tout simplement de d'être exilé
de l'antisémitisme et de l'autre qu'on
soit tout simplement considéré comme
islamophobe parce que on essae du moins
possible si je peux dire de qualifier
les bombardements d'Israël mais moi je
vais vous dire mon opinion je vais être
très honnête moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui
tout le monde souhaite la paix mais d'un
côté ce conflit est tellement complexe
mal parti c'est mal parti et il est
tellement complexe tout le monde
s'invente aujourd'hui moi ce que ce qui
ce qui me ce qui me fait peur c'est que
tout le monde s' expert en géopolitique
aujourd'hui tout à fait oui ça c'est
drame de ma comme toute l'équipe
municipale on préfère vraiment pas
exposer d'apaiseriser ch les choses mais
justement parce que vous parliez de on
parle du du conflit israëlpalestinien on
parle vous parz de Naël on a
l'impression que la moindre
étincelle peut peut mettre le faux
poudre et peut voilà que derrière tout
ça il y a quand même une tension qui est
très forte dans certains un quartier
mais dans le pays en général le pays en
général dans le pays en général on l'a
vu avec l'assassinat de Thomas du jeune
Thomas sa misère on le voit on le voit
bien on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui il y a
un problème il y a une fracture non
seulement sociale mais je dirais aussi
une fracture
idéologique civilisationnelle qui on est
qui on est il y a des personnes qui se
considèrent plus français h et c'est
très grave et c'est souvent nos jeunes
comment c'est possible qu'est-ce que
vous leur dites à cette jeunesse croyez
en vous croyez en la France ne vous
posez pas la question de ce que vous
pouvez ce que le pays peut faire pour
vous mais ce que vous pouvez faire pour
le pays Kennedy Kennedy et et c'est
aussi un message d'espoir et je pense
vous savez pourquoi les jeunes
aujourd'hui préfèrent revendiquer leurs
origines
que le leur origine qui est de base
celle de la France pour la simple et
bonne raison qu'il trouvent aucune
fierté re français
oui c'est ça mais le le vrai problème
est-ce que le vrai problème il va pas là
c'est dans la panne de la République au
fond finalement
mais est-ce que la République elle est
aussi l'état si je peux dire est
comptable de tout encore une fois il y a
eu un problème je vous le dis dans la
transmission des valeurs dans
l'éducation dans la parentalité nous en
tout cas on fait on fait un maximum à
laavrière au sujet de la parentalité
nous essayons de faire des ateliers
parents enfants nous essayons de faire
par exemple des cafés tout toutes les de
semaines dans nos différents quartiers
avec nos seigors pour justement
reconnecter reconnecter pour qu' voilà
qui des ou reconnecter les gens entre
eux qui pas oui qui pas qui a pas ce
sentiment de solitude qui solitude il a
un problème de cohésion social VO bien
il y a un mais il y a toujours de
l'espoir moi je vois les quand je vois
ces belles manifestations justement ces
marches silencieuse où il n'y a pas un
seul débordement ou quand je vois aussi
cette je dirais cette union nationale
face aux attaque thorist du 7 octobre je
me dis qu'il y a encore de l'espoir je
me dis qu'il y a toujours de l'espoir
que la jeunesse c'est l'espérance et
j'aimerais dire à cette jeunesse
engagez-vous peu importe le parti oui il
faut s'engager il faut s'engager si son
on s'engage si qu' on respecte les les
lois les valeurs avec des avec des des
sentiments et des des opinions
différentes mais mais cette jeunesse
qu'on voit là qui on est pas en dehors
mais oui bien sûr mais cette jeunesse je
ne dirais pas que cette jeunesse est
perdue je dirais je dirais pas ça je
dirais simplement qu'elle manque de
repère et ben vous êtes là pour pour
pour essayer de le rendonner et en tout
cas pour pour essayer de faire en sorte
que bah voilà les choses puissent
s'apaiser que les jeunes puissent
trouver peut-être un avenir là où ils
sont et grâce grâce notamment quand même
aux études les études c'est une voie de
réussite mais l'entreriat il y en a
d'autres merci beaucoupci merci
beaucoup y